ومع ذلك فإنه لن يكون هنا وحده اليوم
حول وقف إطلاق النار في غزة
يجب أن يكون أيضًا حول
استئناف محادثات السلام
ومن أجل ذلك وتد تلك النار
بالطبع أولا
هوانغ المطلوبة سوف يستغرق الأمر من قبل
وستدرك هولندا أن الأمر متروك لـ
الجانب الخاطئ من التاريخ
وقفت ولا تزال
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالفلسطينيين
والاعتقاد بأن إسرائيل يمكن أن تحصل على السلام
إنجازه من قبل خصومه
لقتل مثل الـ 75 سنة الماضية
حدث وما زال يحدث
قمة السذاجة
لو كانت إسرائيل مستعدة لصنع السلام
إغلاق على أساس الدولي
النظام القانوني، كان الصراع موجودًا لفترة طويلة
حل الرائد ماتي وكان لديه
هجوم مثل هجوم حماس على أكتوبر نفسه
لم يحدث ولكن إسرائيل تريد ذلك
نهر الدولة اليهودية إلى البحر مع z min
وربما يكون للفلسطينيين مثل هذا الموقف
يصبح تحقيق حقيقي
السلام في المنطقة مستحيل
صنع